[未知] 지금 자매되지 아니면 우린 숨을 줄 거예요.
[未知] 아래, 아래。
[未知] 莫曼尼娜阿西。
[未知] 来个出发。
[未知] 来呀。
[未知] 啊。
[未知] 让真来会会他们。
[未知] 什么？
[未知] 嗯。
[未知] 吃得了。
[未知] 好，这么远。
[未知] 先看这条肉啊。
[未知] 细长条。
[未知] 一条就烂。
[未知] 看你多香。
[未知] 我不是说你。
[未知] 肉肉油排骨。
[未知] 荷兰豆。
[未知] 自在衣摊。
[未知] 走一走。
[未知] 谁说这豆老啊？
[未知] 你豆才老了。
[未知] 喵。
[未知] 我只能说。
[未知] 好美呀。
[未知] 感觉我有点老去吧。
[未知] 你这怎么买到大帽的帽在。
[未知] 挺着急的。
[未知] Jesus。
[未知] Everybody, how are you?
[未知] 河南。
[未知] 河南洛阳。
[未知] 你店是天下最好的小狗。
[未知] 最后呢，我想问大家一个问题。
[未知] 伤伤发铁的行为属于自首吗？
[未知] 你们知道20年前的手机设计。
[未知] 有多超前吗？
[未知] 手机好玩吗？
[未知] 吃不好。
[未知] 你们去村里陪走。
[未知] 你好。
[未知] 衣服了解一下。
[未知] 以前差不多。
[未知] 啊。
[未知] 你们一定都听过。
[未知] 关于他的故事。
[未知] 凤凰鱼飞。
[未知] 他也可以是钢铁战士。
[未知] 自强性。
[未知] 九尾狐。
[未知] 既是祥瑞昌盛之兽。
[未知] 也可以是孩童心中的一样。
[未知] 你心中是否也有张开巨口。
[未知] 饕餮。
[未知] 黑夜无论怎样入堂。
[未知] 白昼也终将到来。
[未知] 现在的日子。
[未知] 是四年后的世界算个屁。
[未知] 他妈的壁计划。
[未知] What are you waiting for?
[未知] He's your dad too.
[未知] 60年前。
[未知] 他从他师傅的手中接过了火种。
[未知] 今天。
[未知] 他把这团火交给了我。
[未知] 师傅说他也许走不了多远。
[未知] 如果以后哪里有人想看。
[未知] 就让我把这团火。
[未知] 带去那。
[未知] 他们五个人再度捧起冠军奖杯。
[未知] 让我们恭喜。
[未知] T1。
[未知] 胜利的意义从来不是我不是了。
[未知] 而是不留遗憾。
[未知] 你的生活并没有错。
[未知] 你热爱的东西也没有错。
[未知] 大胆表达爱意的你也没有错。
[未知] 不被世俗接受的你也没有错。
[未知] 没有什么哥布林。
[未知] 只有向往更好生活的普通人罢了。
[未知] 只要保证自己是健康开心的。
[未知] 这一切就足够了。
[未知] そして。
[未知] 次の曲が始まるのです。